hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
attacking game to share with you from
1957.
on the wide end
Rasheed yasmatinov
and he's playing against Yuri code
okay I think this game does an excellent
job of highlighting an attacker's
mentality
on board Roy Lopez
Berlin defense
we exchange e pawns with this line and
keep Queens on
black is not threatening the bishop why
white has a stronger threat
to take the Knight land and discover
check and next win the queen
so black addresses that
now this is a threat and this is where
White NOW reacts
and goes back to D3
now this attacker's mentality I'm
drawing attention to it is almost as if
with every move the position is scanned
first for forward moves
is there a way it could generate a
threat grab the initiative in some way
what's that I can't
all right fine then I'll back off I'll
give an inch or in this case two
now the suggestion here one of the top
moves is to come all the way back home
Bishop D3 is also a fine move but before
you play in this way you really do have
to
factor in your dark Square Bishop
what's a positive about this post it
observes H7
it's a sensitive Square especially with
the King Knight not around on its
favorite Square securing it
the negative here is this guy
the center Pawn is obstructed not easily
you can easily move it and so you're not
going to be able to get the bishop out
on its natural diagonal so before this
guy goes here you have to have in the
back of your mind I'm going to deploy my
dark Square Bishop on this shorter
diagonal
okay let's get a couple more developing
moves in exchanging Knights a question
now to The Rook where to go can you go
forward do you even have to react
is there something stronger I can do
okay there isn't a great forward move
this tactical shot is not working there
isn't a great follow-up to that you
could scan the position here for lateral
moves this may seem tempting targeting
H7 but there would be this counter punch
G6 and white is all of a sudden the one
reacting to the threat and this guy is
going to have to move
so white backs off in this position
similar to how the bishop backed off
when it was on B5
Yep this guy here just goes
back to ranks now you could also go all
the way back here in fact Let me throw
this position to as a pop quiz
what move might you play here as black
to improve your position feel free to
pause the video
okay those of you that said B6 that's a
fine way to continue preparing to Simply
feed keto try doing that
with the Rook on E3
and you lose
because this shot is now there because
white is able to form a battery on the H
file White's winning
so Rook E3 carries with it a threat it's
addressed with G6
Queen F3 Bishop G7
gotta get the queen side pieces out
expected move B3
Knight gets out of the d-pawn's way
where to go with the bishop
the most forward Square A3 generating a
threat
you may think I'm gonna go to B2 but
this would allow D5
this guy is Poison the Knight is pinned
there's already a threat here with D4
so it's Bishop A3
D6
blocks the bishop opens up the bishop as
well light now doubles
all white pieces are
developed
Knight goes back to F6
H3 okay some defensive move here cuts
out any bishop or knight move more long
term we got the flight Square
this is where black now starts to go
wrong
in the game it's Knight D7 the
suggestion here
is to play Rook B8 secure B7 so that
this guy can get on the main diagonal
in this game though it's Knight D7 now
when I see a move like Knight D7 in this
position
there's a certain move or two that
spring to mind straight away for me
and that is
a night move
this position right here they're both
competing for the same Center Square so
when one Knight decides to move the
other should look to hop into one of
these two squares
so that's exactly what white does and he
goes with the most forward move
Knight D5
the reply here F5
now something that needs to be
covered here is what's happening
if the Knight drops into E5
well these guys aren't here just for
show they're going to blast through
they would blast through
capturing on E5
and if you recapture with the pun here's
a sequence where we're White's gonna
going to win upon what I'm about to show
you White's going to win upon and it's
going to be an opposite color Bishop
position this is all forced
uh well this is at least one forceful
line where yep there we go we're up upon
opposite color Bishop position white of
course
for choice
another line here is a double exchange
sacrifice
if you're recapturing with the bishop
check this out
watch the dark squares get pounced on
the Knight the Queen the Knight the
queen on E7 F6 check this one out Bishop
E7 that stings
she's toast you go here or here it
doesn't matter the Knight lands on F6
and the black queen is a gunner
okay
so we know what we could be doing if
Knight E5 in this game it's F5 and this
is where White NOW sees an opportunity
to move forward to sacrifice some
material to get the queen in an
excellent
post or on an excellent Square Knight
takes C7
Queen takes Knight Queen D5 checks so
it's a night for Pawn imbalance but how
valuable is this guy it's
like a half dead Pawn with this sequence
white is not interested in pond hunting
this may be tempting to take on D6
Landing a fork
if you play in this way
black has an excellent move Knight B6
and now it's considered best to play
Queen C5 exchange Queens not what white
wants
anything else in Black would be
winning if white isn't playing Queen C5
here
okay what is White's idea to take
advantage of the disconnect between the
Rooks black still needs two Tempi before
this guy
is a contributor
so he goes straight in to the back rank
Knight F6
there's a fork here
Rook takes Rook check
Bishop takes rook and let me throw this
position to you as a pop quiz
the Knight observes the queen
how would you reply here
feel free to pause the video
okay
the queen doesn't have to move
the bishop gets on the main diagonal the
Knight
is pinned
Bishop G7
another pop quiz
how would you react in this position
feel free to pause the video
okay white develops his last piece I
don't consider this guy developed from
D3 whether he's on D3 or F1
kind of staring
at
a rock here an F5 or you're on Pawn it
needs to be rerouted
he goes to C4 it's the best move the
only move
that wins Bishop C4 In This Very
position the queen
is poison
this is not a threat
if the queen is captured game over
the bishop is pinned
so white again this attacker's mentality
this wasn't
a threat don't react to this move here
improve one of your own pieces the piece
that wasn't doing
really anything
all white pieces are now functioning
we continue Bishop D7 Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes Bishop Queen F7 she
doesn't really get much more invasive
than this black king in the corner the
queen a Knights move away
in the game Queen Diego's played the
suggestion here is Bishop G5 with the
continuation to disrupt the bishop
if some other move like Bishop G7 is
played there would follow Rook E7 and
its check mate next two pigs on the
seventh rank
if the bishop moves it's Checkmate in
one
and if you defend
the bishop that's also me because we
have this guy on C4
so in this game Queen d8 is played
covering the bishop covering the back
rank but
there's a wonderful final move can you
spot it
feel free to pause the video
okay
here we go Rook E8 check
and black resigns no matter what black
does here it's Checkmate next move
if you capture with the bishop
these two the the queen and the Rook
cannot see these two squares queen f8 or
G8
would be mate
and if you take with the queen
they would follow Queen takes bishop and
look at these two beautiful diagonals
game
over
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye